we've got rich hill i'm sorry for that
making his 13th start of the season like
we talked about in the open since the
first of may 39 and two-thirds innings
and seven starts just three earned runs
given up to go along with 39 strikeouts
he's pitching with a lot of confidence
right now added that change up in his
last start it'll be interesting to see
if he sprinkles that in against the team
that he's going to see an awful lot of
this season
but he has been some kind of good now
the 1-2
and he got him looking strike three
on the outside corner
santander has come off the il
swinging a pretty good bat hitting 320
since coming back 16 of his last 19
games ground ball to third
wendell
one and over to first for the
5-4-3 double play
and for jorge lopez so uh
first win on the 16th of april last
start got him a bunch of runs pitched
well enough to beat the
cleveland indians in baltimore era has
come down
ground ball through the open left side
they had only franco over there
and now hit what would normally be a
ground ball to short
right through the wide open left side
for a base hit
and a four-pitch walk right there
the first two men are on base
three-two
and meadows down swinging lopez using
the change-up early and effectively
well wendell has been pretty good in
these situations he's hitting 288
overall
326 against right-handers
on the ground down to third base side
fair
that will get a run home
wow scores
into third goes giandi diaz and in the
second windall and the range lead one
nothing
two more men in scoring position for
margot
a little tap that's going to be a tough
play
bare hand attempt
nothing going there the run scores diaz
crosses the plate and it's two nothing
here's kevin keermeyer
there's a broken background ball deep
short no place to go with it a run will
score
wendell crosses the plate down has
looked at sec and margola was going to
be there anyway
but a misfire and tier meyer is aboard
the rays have a three-nothing lead
sometimes a good night's sleep will
rejuvenate you too we should try that
once in a while
how about the quick pitch
and a fly ball right center who's gonna
grab this one that's phillips little
crisscross
phillips and kierbyer phillips made the
grab
bottom half of inning two coming three
nothing raised
and a cut in the miss
[Applause]
so three pitches one out
strikeout number two for hill
and that is strike three call the
curveball
and so it was a very quick
top half of the third that curveball
breaking
to get wins
so a one two three inning
it's gonna be interesting
we're gonna find out a lot more these
coming weeks and months we think here a
good third for lopez one two three with
a strikeout question really is oh at the
end and we'll let this play out and get
back to
waltz goes to lao for one and two diaz
for two
six four three on the double play that's
the second one of the game here for rich
hill
the pitcher's best friend
or do they have this guy be the guy if
they think they're going to be a pretty
good team in a couple of years
lifted into center
hillmeyer is there
to make the catch
graves lead three-nothing
zanino tags one into the ship makes a
nice play by valencia and galvez gets
the back how about that exchange
volleyka the second baseman
on the left side and he finds galves
because of positioning
oh look out
phillips hit by that pitch
they mistook that and phillips is having
some fun two men on with two men out
this one's headed toward left and it's
going to drop for a base hit and now it
bounds away
mount castle had that one get by and
zanino's already scored here comes
phillips he will score and lau winds up
at
so hayes is out on strikes
and it's a cut and a miss
franco is out on strikes
this one really good one of the better
ones of the day he kept it in the zone
the entire way and still got the swing
and a miss so bases loaded for the
orioles catcher
wins with a fly ball in the left field
margot to the wall this is gone
grand slam austin wins
the first career grand slam in the big
leagues for austin wins and you're back
in the game
and strike three call how about that
what an inning in the six from a cube
one two three via the strikeout
a couple of strikeouts and a walk from
scott in the inning
runner goes wins throw to second is
there
a grand slam and a caught stealing and a
two-inning span for austin wins how do
you
do a wave and a miss
the strikeout of wins
strikeout number five for mccue
five four rays
a fly ball here in the seventh
and a ground ball from margot to short
galvez tidies it up and the orioles are
out of the inning
thanks to a little help from austin
hayes in right field
still a one-run game
3-2
he got a
fastball by him
it's a one-two-three-eighth as fairbanks
strikes out santander
and diaz attacks the first pitch out to
right hayes is there and the orioles are
out of the eighth
two outs amanda bourne in a one-run game
and the 3-2 again
little tapper charged by wendell in the
glove and out the rays win it
and the rays hang on to win this game
5-4